[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ces allégories ouais c'est trop
c'est pour éviter que vous irez bagnols
il explique aux téléspectateurs est ce
que ça arrive quelque chose ecoutons-la
essayer c'est pas trop mal toi ta gueule
aussi face à dia ne fut pas mal
j'aime bien
et met ses effets mais sera connaissez
alors attention est ce qu'on peut lui
montrer ce qui va vraiment faire oui oui
oui mais est-ce qu'on peut
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
m
ce soir exceptionnellement va vers
quelque chose qu'on a pas l'habitude de
faire mais moi cette ville est ici vous
allez jouer aussi plus c'est moi oui
j'adore vous avez assez plus c'est moi
vous allez gagner vous allez choix pour
indemniser les cheveux face à jour pour
mac rabat sa dynamique celle où vous
allez partir quand la prochaine fournée
pour las vegas avec toute l'équipe de
cyril hanouna 0 6 1